foreign
I was listening to our friend Mike Rose
podcast the other day and he had an
author on uh Nick eberstott or everstat
I don't know if I don't know how to
pronounce it but um I should have
listened to Mike pronounce it because
with his wonderful pipes it was a great
job of pronouncing it right but but uh
you know Mike has been sounding the same
alarm that you and I have been sounding
particularly you that
um we have a uh what you were saying at
the break is a social crisis evolving
and it's showing up in the unemployment
numbers uh when we properly
measure them now uh this economist is a
mathematician that did this book uh how
things work uh was the I guess that's
Mike's podcast uh I don't see the name
of his book off the top of my head
somebody handed it to me the other day
at an event I believe it's Men at Work
if I'm not mistaken something along with
the uh uh
the essence of their discussion that you
and I have been having a similar
discussion is this um
uh shift in the workplace right now that
uh
we've got a large number of jobs
available and no one applying for them
there's a shortage of labor for the
first time in post-war or to America
we've never seen this in modern America
and the reason there's a shortage is not
because the jobs are so plentiful it's
because there are according this article
from Fox News quoting micro and quoting
this economist there are now 7 million
able-bodied males
between 25 and 40 years old that are
able to work and are not even looking
for work yeah that's correct and it's
it's staggering and so the point here is
is that uh what's going on this is
causing massive economic problems before
we look at the social very quick glance
here when you have a gap in the jobs
like we've had now for the last two
years then you've got real small
businesses being hurt by this think
about the restaurants in your small town
they can't find people to work and it's
affecting their livelihood then the
other economic factor is of course we
saw and we still see a war for talent
and so wages have gone up tremendously
in the last two years which has now led
to a stubborn inflationary period that
we're in now that's the economic piece
the social piece what's crazy about this
is is that you've got
um 6.8 million people that last last
month according to the latest jobs
report and the Census Bureau a hundred
million Americans weren't working last
month now half of 100 million 100 100
million but half were working no I've
got hold on no we don't have a hundred
million unemployed there's only 300
million didn't say they were unemployed
I'm saying just not working period I'm
just breaking the numbers down oh yeah
half are retired okay okay another 12
percent are dealing with some type of
long-term illness so they're or
disability okay and then 5.6 million
people saying I don't want to go back to
work because they're scared of covid and
then the number is right at 7 million
that are saying I don't want to work and
those are the men so the social Factor
that's going on here is you've got two
factors one you've had decades and
Decades of entitlements starts with
welfare and then if you look at during
covet where people were getting payments
every week every month all right so
that's that's an entitlement where
they're disincentivized to actually go
back to work and then Dave I think the
fact that for decades we've we've
literally uh taken the pain away from
our kids we've removed the struggle and
I don't say this with Jess but I think
when you look at things like everybody
gets a trophy for participation and
nobody learns The Sting of failure
nobody learns The Sting of rejection so
what happens is a good amount of the
seven million men not all of them are in
this conversation that Mike had with
this economist are looking at screens
based on the data they say how much time
they spend on screens they get dope
thousands 2 000 year hours a year two
thousand hours seven million men 25 to
54 are spending 2 000 hours a year so
self-medicating because they're scared
to leave the cave using your old analogy
not cave it's Mother's basement right
but the idea is they're afraid to put
themselves out there and here's what we
know about work so when someone succeeds
in work their self-esteem goes up two
they have Financial Independence or the
opportunity for Financial Freedom and
then three they're part of something
bigger than themselves it's a sense of
belonging Dr John deloney will tell you
your mental health goes up because your
dignity your autonomy that's it your
ability to control your environment goes
up there is such a
uh mental illness tie-in no question
caused by not working that's right uh
literally the so this idea that you have
not put gravel in the stomach of your
kids they have no grit means as a parent
you suck
and so you mommies need to throw your 25
year old out of his out of your basement
yesterday and uh put him on the street
and teach him to work you're late to the
party but you need to do this you are
doing him a disservice you are doing
America a disservice you are doing your
neighbors a disservice you're doing the
Mental Health Community a disservice
you're risking his increased likelihood
of depression anxiety and suicide that's
exactly right you are you are doing all
of these things because you're letting
Junior play Call of Duty 2 000 hours a
year in your basement and he ain't never
been called to any Duty yeah and the
irony is is you're doing all of that
under the guise of helping your kid feel
good about themselves and the very thing
that they need to feel good about
themselves is to go out and do good it's
the wussification of America yeah yeah
it's just a bunch of wussies yeah is
what it amounts to and you know
seriously a good cowboy boot in the butt
of this whole thing would be helpful it
really really would it just pisses me
off I mean this is just a thing where
you just need to work oh my God seven
million and they saw they call them men
in this article I'll call them males
all right males 25 50 25 to 40 7 million
of them literally sitting on their butts
and someone else is caring for them the
government uh their mommy
their living girlfriend
who thinks he's cute
um here's the breakdown Sugar Mama do
you buddy here's a uh here's some of the
census day today from a Bloomberg
article the equivalent of 32 million
people aren't working are relying on
savings that includes retirement okay uh
another 26 million are using credit
cards or loans and 12 million have been
following credit card is the devil it's
at the center of the problem there it is
and then here's the but here's the part
we've been talking about 12 million have
said that they're borrowing from family
or friends to help keep them out of the
workforce yeah they're living off family
and friends you're enablers you're
giving a drunk a drink you're giving a
lazy person the ability to still be lazy
you're giving someone who's in avoidance
mode because they're afraid they're
scared they're Paralyzed by the facing
reality and stepping into the real world
when the best thing that can happen to
you the most alive you'll ever feel is
when you risk it and you step up to the
plate and the ball comes twizzing across
and scares the piss out of you while you
swing the bat this is the best thing
that can happen to you and you strike
out right and it's okay right sometimes
it doesn't work out oh darn well I think
the the simplest way to look at what
David says remember all of us when we
rode a bike the first time we were
terrified horrified maybe I'm terrified
right now yeah but what happened like we
took that fear we stepped into it we
learned to ride the bike and it wasn't
much longer before we were saying look
Mom no hands we go from terrified to get
on the bike to look Mom no hands and
that's the human Spirit the idea of
these kids these men I shouldn't say
kids but some of them are emotionally
kids they need to feel alive and the way
you feel alive is by making a
contribution for yourself and for
listeners you don't feel alive where
there's no risk well that's exactly
right and coddling the coddling of the
American male the wussification of this
culture it is really starting to be a
social problem it started out as a
parenting problem it started out as this
and hey man I don't know do we
no I'm just gonna blame you moms and
dads well I would say the friends and
the parents are absolutely you know I
can blame Call of Duty if you want but
moms and dads that are good moms and
dads rip that crap out of the wall and
say get your butt out and mow the grass
here's one other one we the people
taxpayers we gotta quit giving these
morons and money to sit on their butts
no more government entitlements that's
where we the people can do something
it's just not good for the [ __ ] it's
not good for the government and it's not
good for us
to morons day okay really oh my gosh
Dave's like the soundtrack to all my
policies